I'm pretty sure I've been doing uh this
version of The Matrix for a
while and I'm pretty sure it's Rob
thorburn who uh who showed me that
version one of the organizers of Play
Festival which I am going to this year
in August and you should come because
it's amazing the
Matrix so first off if you're going to
play with moves like this
uh warm up really warm up you're it's
you're doing a back bend um while
focusing on POI that is definitely a way
you might tweak your back that means
literally getting your body temperature
raised so your your core temperature is
up sweating a little bit and you've
loosened up do some back bends without
the POI just making sure you feel
comfortable and strong and confident
that you can do it with poy and your
back's going to be fine so the the
version that I'm
showing is a version that uses the 4
beat cork screw so that's your
prerequisite you need to be able to do a
very controlled four beat cork screw and
if you can do
it you can go into the Matrix from the
four beat so the trick is it actually
begins not on the way up you begin it on
the way down so look at the pattern here
I'm going clockwise my right po the
orange one is leading it wind it leads
around my left to go up and around my
left to go down snakes its way up snakes
its way down so do this clockwise with
me first thing I want you to do is just
notice as your right hand snakes down it
passes your
belly the first beat below your hands is
the right P coming past your belly
that's where the whole move is going to
begin and you need to be really boom
find that and be really clear of where
that moment is
then you're going to instead of doing it
at your belly you're just going to bring
it over so it's kind of at your
ribs so neutral it's going to be right
at your belly button maybe right at your
sternum Bo you're just going to go turn
with it a bit so that right Point passes
your ribs
there that's the first thing next thing
we're going to skip forward a little bit
and uh talk about how to come out of the
Matrix the middle of the Matrix is going
to be a totally neutal position here
you're leaning back a little bit each
hand is kind of at your its own ear and
you're just here
hanging you're going to tilt to your
left you're going to let the PO rotate
clockwise until the right wrist is
snagging on the left wrist and that's
where you'll go back up into the fourbe
cork screw and that's all it is to come
out of the Matrix you start here if you
tilt to the right your play are
naturally going to start spinning
clockwise until you see where to hook
up here you are lean po go around hooks
into the four beat cork screw so as you
practice it'll just slowly get more
natural till you
go lean spin hook up and you're back to
your
Forbe the way you get into it we're
going to freeze
this
moment your left arm is here your right
PO is in front and see your wrists are
kind of hook so your right PO is close
to you your wrist is going around your
left
wrist so that's the position we'll be
in from here if I let the PO start to go
a bit
clockwise the left comes around that's
my neutral
position then I continue oop back to my
Quirk screw so again we're
here they start to go clockwise the left
comes around the head then the Right
comes around the head back to your cork
screw the right is here and make sure
you're not on this side you got to be on
this
side
lean the left comes around the head
that's your neutral position right goes
around Corkscrew with a little practice
you get the here left comes around right
comes around cork
screw left comes around that's your
neutral right around cork
screw and that will
become your
Matrix you can add things in the middle
of the Matrix you can
add you can open it do an extra spin
blah blah um super fun move again I
stress make making sure you're you're
warmed up um and stretched out a bit
it's one of those things where don't
keep pushing it when you know you should
stop respect your body and have
fun and come the Play Festival
[Music]